[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
distinguished Gus the president of the
United States accompanied by the t-shock
of Ireland
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hello hello
happy St Patrick's Day
[Applause]
take a seat if you have one gov
I'm getting a little bit worried we're
in here watching it and the T-shirt when
we're in you're on camera
in that Senator Coons
what the hell you been doing crazy I
don't know at any rate he's the senator
from Delaware
[Applause]
as a great great grandson of the bluets
of County Mayo and several are here
today
and the Finnegans of County louth who
boarded coffin ships across the Atlantic
more than 165 years ago
as a proud son of Catherine Eugenia
Finnegan Biden I wish you all a very
very happy St Patrick's Day
this Gathering is a cherry tradition a
celebration to honor where we all come
from and where we're heading it's a time
for us to tell stories maybe share a few
Irish bits of Irish poetry and uh not to
live in some romanticized version of the
past but to remember remember what's
possible what's possible as we recommit
ourselves to The Unfinished work that
lies ahead of all of us
you know I often say we Irish are the
only people in the world who are
nostalgic for the future
I think that's true by the way
and uh but now the Diplomat Leslie Shane
once wrote Every St Patrick's Day every
Irishman goes out to find another
Irishman to make a speech to
I said that this morning so I that's why
we ask you to hear so we can make
speeches
luckily we don't have to go too far
today
you know T-shirt has been wonderful to
welcome you to the White House and uh
and spend some time with you and Matthew
today and it's always a moment of great
Unity uh here in Washington I mean that
sincerely
I've been doing this for a few years and
it never ceases to please me how
committed so many people are Democrats
and Republicans a like share deep
respect and love of Ireland as you saw
this morning that that actually that's
early afternoon up in Capitol Hill
this afternoon
many of my good friends in Congress on
both sides of the aisle are here today
including the former Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi a good Irish leader
and Tisha I've said this before
I think she's the best speaker in the
history of the United States
members of my cabinet are here or
Ambassador Island Claire Cronin from
Boston Massachusetts here she's in
Dublin Claire
she's asked me when the term is up
whether or not she can still stay in one
of the rooms here
it's a hell of a place to declare
that's not bad I also want to welcome
the Ambassador from Ireland in the
United Kingdom as well as members of the
Irish and British parliaments you all
stand up if you're here
welcome welcome welcome
we even got a few
of my distant Irish cousins here today
including the well-known Irish Rugby
player Rob Kearney Rob stand up
I want to see you after this pal
you know Rob I expect
we know and there's no offense to anyone
but who in the room we're rooting for in
the Grand Slam match between Ireland
England
not
I'm looking forward to that anyway
and one of the more special guests is
here today is Morris Baron Morris grew
up in on the Emerald Isle fell in love
with his wife Candice and uh in New York
City and they got married the same
Chapel that Jill and I got married and
my wife Jill and I in New York not long
afterwards their uh their baby daughter
Ava was born she was diagnosed with a
rare form of cancer
they were told the odds of her survival
were only five percent
but as uh was it was a long hard
treatment but Ava never quit fighting
and uh on those hardest days Morris
found comfort in reading a book my wife
had written about our family's cancer
Journey with our son and others and when
Ava was finally declared cancer-free
Morris wrote me a letter that said quote
your strength gave me strength
and he and his wife were Jill's guests
at the State of the Union this year to
share our message of Faith and Hope for
the world
and it's good to welcome him back to the
White House where are you
thank you
attention
your strength gave me strength pal this
is a fact
I didn't realize he'd been living on a
third floor all this time
but uh I wonder what that noise up there
has been
to me that's what
that's what friendship between Ireland
United States is all about We rise
together and our Joys and our triumphs
we persevere together in our sorrows and
our setbacks and we dream together over
Horizons we can't even see and we build
together a future that may be that may
be and in this these rooms we see the
dreams of one Irish Builder made real
when George Washington chose James Hoban
to design the White House the young
architect had his credentials had his
credential a silver medal from the
Dublin Society
and around the outside of that metal
inscribed in Latin was the phrase our
work bears fruit
it's a statement of faith
and a statement of determination
a statement of possibility and promise
and she shook standing with you today it
captures pretty well all all of our
Nations all that our nation our people
have achieved together Ireland and
America have written ourselves a better
future
the United States has benefited greatly
from waves of immigration from the
Ireland the island of Ireland who help
shape this nation the Scottish Irish of
the 18th century the Irish who came
during the 19th Century Century like my
ancestors doing the famine and Beyond
and Through The Bravery in their blood
the honest sweat of their brow and the
steadfast Hearts their work has borne
centuries of fruit
and their values have been passed down
generation to generation around
countless irish-american dinner tables
just like the one I grew up in
you know my in many times as I hear my
dad say Joey everyone's your equal
everyone's your equal but nobody's
better than you everyone's equal
nobody's better than you enjoy
Everyone's entitled to be treated with
dignity it was a favorite word I think
the word is used by the Irish more than
almost any other word dignity and Joey
as long as you're alive you have an
obligation to strive
and you're not dead to have seen the
face of God never give up growing up
Irish American gave me the pride that
spoke to both sides of the Atlantic
heart and soul that Drew from the old
and the new
my great-grandfather after Francis
blewitt was one of the I think he's only
the second Irish Catholic ever elected
to the state senate in the in
Pennsylvania the time when not many
Catholics were elected to office
he had an engineering degree from
Lafayette College in the heart of an
Irish poet in 1919 in one of over 100
poems that I found in my when my mom
passed away in her Treasures he wrote
about his Ireland and one stands he
wrote The Following
from the fairest land except my own nice
son and star and moon The Citadel of
Liberty my mother's land a rune
today around the world Ireland and the
United States continue to stand shoulder
to shoulder to defend those core values
that make up the essential character of
each of our Nations
we're standing together to support the
brave people of Ukraine as they defend
their democracy against Russia's brutal
invasion
and standing tight
I want to thank you for that
I want to thank
particularly thank the t-shirt for the
generosity of the people of Ireland
welcoming refugees fleeing violence in
Ukraine
we're holding Russia accountable for its
aggression
and for its war crimes and crimes
against humanity that Russia is
committing as I speak in Ukraine we're
also working together to take on issues
that are going to shape the kind of
world in which our children will live
we're tracking the climate crisis we're
tackling it we're strengthening the
global health and promoting food
security and together we seek a world
that's safer more prosperous more
peaceful for people everywhere this year
we will celebrate a momentous
achievement in our shared history the
hard hard work of forging The Good
Friday agreement and I want to thank the
folks that are here as well for
participating in that nearly
nearly 25 years ago seems hard to
believe it's been that long 25 years ago
delivered to Decades of peace and
prosperity for all the people in
Northern Ireland my really good friend
is my great friend I wish he could be
here today George Mitchell is a good man
who worked tirelessly with the people
from every Community to achieve that
breakthrough
always holding fast to their faith and
their shared future for the people of
Northern Ireland folks now it's
incumbent on all of us to continue to
Foster that peace to continue to find
common cause so their work may continue
to bear fruit for generations to come
tishook we both agree that the recently
announced Windsor framework
is an important step we had a long
discussion with the Prime Minister of
Great Britain about that a couple weeks
a week ago in California that's going to
preserve and strengthen the Good Friday
agreement
in the past few weeks I've shared my
support for the framework with both the
European commission president as well
the president of vanderline and the
Prime Minister says he is going to
continue to push
I also meet here to see Joe Kennedy III
the nephew a new
but where were you Joe
the new special Envoy Northern Ireland
for economic affairs
doing a good job Joe getting down to
work with all the communities in
Northern Ireland to help realize their
extraordinary economic potential
I joined the people across Northern
Ireland looking forward to seeing the
return of a devolved government
Democrats sharing power and governance
is the heart of the Good Friday
agreement I want to recognize five
Northern Irish political party leaders
are here today gentlemen would you
please stand
and ladies
sorry
as I said today on Capitol I want to
thank you all for standing together with
Chief Constable Byrne and in the wake of
the attempted murder of detective Chief
Inspector Caldwell
it was an important show of unity
refusal to return to violence even after
nearly 25 years we can't take for
granted a shared future built on peace
in Northern Ireland we can't fail in our
effort to seek compromise and
cooperation for the good of everyone and
I want each of you to know that the
United States will remain a strong
friend and partner in the work that lies
ahead the Republic of Ireland today is a
country with a past that tugs at your
heart and a future that's shaping the
world and as a global force and culture
and the Arts and evidenced by the 14
Oscar nominations went to Irish artists
this year
well I think the most important thing is
a voice for moral leadership in the
world stage
it's a driver of the economic and
technological development of our world
and there's no limit to where the
partnership between our Nations can take
us
let me end with this
everything between Ireland the United
States runs deep our Joys our sorrows
our passions
our Drive our dreams our optimism
even in the most difficult of moments
even the darkest moments of the scare
despair we hold on to hope hope
We Believe In A Better Tomorrow
we see a world not of a shrinking
opportunity but of unlimited
possibilities we see a future that knows
no bounds remember Sheamus Haney's poem
his wife was kind enough to send me
another copy of it
The Cure Troy he wrote quote history
history says don't hope on this side of
the grave
but then once in a lifetime that long
four tidal wave of Justice Rises up and
hope and history rhyme
ladies and gentlemen this is an age
where we can once more make hope in
history Ramen I believe with every fiber
in my being and I've been doing this a
long time
That's The Power of this friendship
I really believe it and that's the
strength of our partnership
and simply put as my father would say my
mother would say that's the Irish of it
Tisha the floor is yours
[Applause]
Mr President Madam vice president second
gentleman Senators Representatives
ladies and gentlemen
as we know every American president is a
little bit Irish on St Patrick's Day
but some are more Irish than others
and um
I think it's fair to say that today
we're celebrating our national day with
a president who is unmistakably a son of
Ireland
President Biden in your life story we
see reflected the story of Ireland
it's a story of service and patriotism
of family of courage in the face of
tragedy and above all unswerving faith
in the future
so tonight we recall the blue it's of
County Mayo and the Finnegans of County
louth and all those who left Ireland to
find a new dream in a new land in this
land
this year in Ireland we celebrated a new
national holiday in honor of Saint
Bridget who's one of our three patron
saints
Bridget represents women New Life the
spring and inspires us to make our
society a better and more equal place
column kill represents learning and
engagement with the world and inspires
us to play our part in the community of
Nations
and Patrick represents Above All Else
Liberty
the escaped slave and migrant who came
to Ireland and ended up teaching us
about Christianity and The Wider world
of which we were apart
as you know Legend has it that Patrick
rid Ireland of its snakes
but we know now that there were no
actual snakes in Ireland at the time or
at least there is no evidence that there
ever having been any snakes at that
particular time but of course this is
often the case this this is symbolic and
the snakes were symbols
symbolic of ignorance of fear of Despair
and cynicism
and Ireland is a country that I believe
is full of Hope
hope that we can fix the problems that
we Face both home and abroad
and full of Hope for what we can achieve
by working together with each other and
our friends
our dream of an independent country and
statehood secured a hundred years ago
would not have been possible I believe
without the support of the United States
and the solidarity
and the solidarity of so many Irish
Americans down the generations who
helped us to achieve our national
self-determination
next month as you all know we we Mark
the 25th anniversary of the Good Friday
Belfast agreement
it could never have been achieved
without steadfast support and commitment
of President Biden and so many others
who are here in this room today
and we know that at especially difficult
or fragile moments in the search for
peace successive presidents from both
sides of the aisle stepped in with words
of encouragement
hand on the shoulder or even a gentle
shove in the right direction
we remember president karcher's policy
statement on Northern Ireland in August
1977 expressing American concern and
urging that we should find a peaceful
Way Forward and our prayers are with
that fine man and his family at this
particular time
President Ronald Reagan
spoke of finding a just and peaceful
solution knowing that Justice and peace
went together on St Patrick's Day in
1981 a phrase that was echoed by
President Bill Clinton and Darius
guildhall 14 years later
Mr President carried in these words was
the promise of American solidarity
a promise that was kept and fulfilled
blessed are the peacemakers and blessed
are those who keep the peace alive
and above all those like President Biden
who keep the faith
and so this year as we marked that
anniversary we looked at the future and
all that still needs to be done
our mission now is to find ways of
realizing the potential for everyone who
calls Ireland home
we want to see the institutions of the
Good Friday agreement restored so they
can provide hope for a new generation
and we'd like to see the people of
Northern Ireland benefit from the rich
economic opportunities available to them
around the world
the flame of Freedom Burns brightly
despite the efforts of those who were
distinct extinguish it
our Collective freedom is imperiled by
the damage we're doing to our planet
our changing climate and the loss of
biodiversity
and Russia's brutal war against Ukraine
has reminded us that freedom can never
be taken for granted
and when we defend Freedom abroad we
also protect our own Freedom at home
[Applause]
to honor the many generations of
Americans who helped make our dream of
Freedom a reality
and as a permanent reminder of the
strong and everlasting relationship
between our two countries earlier on
today I brought a special gift from
Ireland this year
it wasn't the Mayo Jersey which we
brought as well it was in fact our
tri-color which is a national symbol of
peace reconciliation and hope and
through its colors it symbolizes the two
traditions on our Island the green and
orange
and the promise of lasting peace and a
new dispensation between them
a dream of a shared future on a shared
Island
this special flag which I presented to
President Biden earlier
was flown just once before at an event
in Waterford to Mark the 175th
anniversary of the first flight of our
flag in Ireland
that very first tri-color was flown in
on the mall in Waterford by Thomas
Francis Maher a 24 year old idealist who
later fought for freedom in this country
and some of the bloodiest battles in the
American Civil War
his bravery and that of the Irish
Brigade was so great that when President
Lincoln visited one of the battlefields
it said he kissed the Irish colors
saying God bless the Irish flag
so present I hope that this flag will
find a permanent home in this white
house as a reminder of the unbreakable
bonds between our countries and our
people
it represents our values and our history
as well as our faith and what we can
achieve together in the future
so thank you Mr President for the very
warm welcome that you've extended to me
and my delegation on this very special
occasion
we look forward to welcoming you in
Ireland very soon look forward to
welcoming you home
and I know that you'll be received with
open arms and the Very warmest of hearts
thank you very much and a very happy
Saint Patrick's Day